hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on Le
chest.org going to hop into another
hourly rapid
Arena 10 plus
Z catching the last hour of
this three games maybe
four let's see who we get round one 265
in
here okay te one
back to
tournament okay quick resigner ooh can I
get first
place all right player did not want to
play so we'll see I guess we're going to
get four games maybe
five okay real game
one
E4
The Giver
9 all right let's play an open
Sicilian black should take with the pawn
and not with the
Knight just improve my queen she's
stable in the center would
be okay I think what you are supposed to
play here it's Knight B5 focus on the
weakness of this last move one of the
weaknesses at
least D6 is a hole D5 as a
hole and it seems this is a step in the
wrong
direction I do have a convenient
reply Knight
C3 and I'm still eyeing up Knight D6
uh the only other move I'm considering
is Bishop here
but I don't like blocking my Queen's
view of D6 so I'm just going to
develop I'm not concerned that I'm in a
pin I have security with the peace
upon Bishop there so this is not a
threat I do have coverage with the
bishop on
B5 I could hop in straight
away if I play
A3 I'm not even threatening to
take I don't think at least I'm not sure
if I could get some Queen
trap
so I'm thinking about diving right in
straight away or continuing to Simply
develop
and maybe wait for my knight to be
nudged into
D6 let me give that a
go Bishop C4 targeting the weakest
Square
F7 it's unprotected
now so Queen D5 Queen H5
moves can be serious all right so
now um get castle or Knight
D6 I know why I want to just wait for my
knight to be
kicked
although oh no actually at this stage I
think I want to hop
in Bishop takes Queen
takes how is my
queen kicked away from that square I
guess Queen B4
but I'm not too concerned about
that have the bishop PA I have a dark
Square
Bishop
um what is best castles do I do I want a
queen exchange that's another
thing castles
castles and
then let me just go with
castles maybe I'd play A3 on my next
move after
castles again I'm not threatening it
straight away okay now the bishop has
taken a step
so Knight D6
here looks
interesting yeah I think I'm going to go
in for it now
Queen is going to
be I think a
pest surprised that black is giving this
one a think
here cuz I am on F7 if you don't take
the Knight so on Queen B4 I do have the
option
oh did not even consider that
one okay so you're on
C2 got
it
okay if I play here there's this one
Queen is defending
this um wondering
if I mean it almost feels like I
could play this
one maybe not even care about C2 I'm not
going
to I was going to say I'm not really
going to calculate a whole
lot yeah I'm going to I'm going to go
with this one seeing this
takes something good should be happening
for
me okay they are going in for that now I
do see a variation where they could get
the Queens off it's another detail now I
might want to consider forcing moves
here so take take and then take Discover
check or just take here straight
away yeah I'm going to do
that so I really don't know how this is
all playing out there should be if if
I'm not able
to kind of do something with these
pieces and the
queen I don't know if I could rely upon
the queen but if they take my Rook I
think I could
uh take
here and then play Bishop here so Knight
takes Rook Bishop takes Pawn check King
here Bishop here and even if they get
the Queens off or actually on the check
I could just move King H1 so something
like this bishop takes
Pawn King d8 Bishop G5 Queen B6 King H1
Queen takes Queen Pawn takes and then
got the this pinned
KN so this is another note maybe maybe I
just play
here yeah instead of
inviting the uh exchange instead of
having this open file for them going I
go with this
one so we'll
see okay so I'm on the
Knight Knight takes Rook Bishop takes
Pawn followed up with Bishop G5 we could
have a two Bishop's mate this Pawn clogs
up the queen side quite a
bit in general not
my uh type of play
here tactical very
sharp okay so I guess they were fearful
of Knight B5 but they're overlooking I
guess this one it should just be
completely winning
now
yeah yeah I think we're going to have a
bishop here and a rook here for me very
soon definitely this stage I do not care
about the Rook these are enough to weave
a
mate probably don't even need the
Knight first things first Rook here it's
the only
move to delay
mate this guy can't even
move so what's the mate Rook
here take the Rook King takes Bishop
takes rook and there's no stopping Rook
f8 next
mate is there okay so this is just
straight to
mate all right I'm not entirely sure if
that was
sound kind of went by feeling on that
one recognizing the backward development
by black on the queen side
primarily okay the jet let's try D4 game
another
white all
right
uh let's play something I don't normally
play Knight
C3 okay no D5 there so let's put the
second Pawn in the center so that's a
hole um I'm going go well now that this
guy's here I don't have to worry about I
I need to slow down
actually um still in like a a
blitz
mentality
so let's
consider I don't have to worry about a
pin now so I could rely upon this Knight
on F3 I won't have to maybe invest a
move to preserve a knight on
F3 I think I want to play with three
Pawns in the
center especially with this
weakness I think eventually I want to
get that Alpha zero Pawn established on
E5 it's
not the only way to play it of course
this is perfectly
healthy maybe just more to the
point yeah let's play more I guess more
direct
maybe try and play sharp
throughout I don't know
okay
okay I'll put this guy here I'm not
quite sure where this guy belongs I kind
of am drawn towards this arange
ment okay it seems like they're going
Hedgehog
land H6 to preserve the
bishop I'm ready to Castle Queens side
maybe where's the pawn
break
H okay if this move isn't
played okay should be doing pretty well
here get that dark Square Bishop
off yeah I think H6 was really the the
way to go so this
queen should
be really
annoying so now I could even
consider H4
H5
yeah yeah let me do
that
I haven't committed my king So Queen
side is still perfectly
healthy with these
three I like my Knights I like my
Center these two still need to
develop
okay feels like it should be winning for
white could play
E5 or just leave the center fluid
and swing the back completely around
this is what I'm drawn
towards kind of saying if you take me
you're helping my queen Knight drift
towards the king side where
I'm trying to
attack I would expect if this move to be
CH my Center to be challenged with C5 or
F6 so I think
it's best to maybe play H5 here I'm now
deciding between these
two yeah I think I want to play this
first so there's a variation maybe with
a capture or a capture here and then
Knight F5 or takes takes takes and then
Knight F5 to extract my
queen I may have some in betweener
though that's another detail if you take
on H6 first queen takes and then Pawn
takes I'm already ready to take on G6
and deliver made on H
s so we'll see what
the jaet comes up with
so so even here for
instance I'm not locked into taking an
E4 could take
here I am on the Rook so takes King
takes and then Pawn takes G6 Pawn takes
Knight Queen
H6
king would have to go
here and then we should be getting a
mate I think I'm going to take
here my knight could all okay yeah I'm
going to take
here this guy should be
poison so have another case here where
there's this backward development on the
queen
side should just be
winning this could be an unprotected
Pawn very soon I would think this is a
case where you want to take away from
the
center not just so The Rook has an open
file but this is more about granting the
king of new Square to
run once I land on
H6 so we'll see what black comes up with
this
this I'm not seeing a defense
really how's this playing out to mate if
they take here exactly check
here
check
um not seeing it
clearly
it's very close I'm I'm I'm almost
certain there is a mate there cuz I
could even afford a quiet move along the
way there's no checks for black in the
position and the closer the king is
pulled towards my side of the board the
less material I'll need to weave a
mate oh I'm also forgetting that my Rook
could also be stepping up to deliver
checks
okay
so it's looking like this one followed
up with Knight G5 should be pretty
crushing and the queen might end up
getting
smothered yeah let's begin with the
check the
runner so this I'm going to hold off on
that so check King
here and then here on the
queen
attacking for free at this stage I'm not
down any material
really
no no pce down
position yeah let's go with Knight
G5 so there's going to be a fork one way
or the
other okay so there is a way out I
believe so on Knight takes Pawn there is
Knight
F5
Knight takes Pawn Knight
F5 I could
play Queen takes
Pawn that should be good
enough no check still for
black yeah let's grab this oh also I'm
forgetting I could I could do it like
this too Queen takes rook and then take
here but I think best is to just take
another Pawn be on this guy still be on
the queen and the rook and this if the
queen moves maybe track down that guy
still no checks for
black or maybe maybe I do make it
simple yeah this queen
here a check I mean I I'm at this stage
I kind of don't want to have to
calculate being a bit down on the
clock all right yeah let's let's just
run it like this where I win the
exchange and I end up with the Rook a
wild Rook on the H oh actually I'm I'm
mistaken I don't have Rook takes
H7 okay taking the center Pawn should be
perfectly fine and this is
a super convenient way to
defend King is cozy C2 is defended
Knight is
attacked so I am up a full
Rook
and I think at this stage we just mop up
some
material I can meet this with C3 or even
this
okay I'm going to go with this
one just get rid of
material take take take C3 I get the
piece that should be clean
enough yeah pretty sure as soon as that
battery is formed you flick in H6
preserve that dark Square
Bishop
signed all right still 35 minutes to
go
336 are in here
all right team
black how
about
Sicilian okay C3 Sicilian saying this in
the last rapid video I put out been
experimenting with this move meeting E5
with returning the Knight back
home not the
best
but
um yeah I'm looking
to maybe work on this Square get a
knight here at some stage or really
another detail is to get some defined F
or a fixed structure in the
center I'll be meeting D4 with Knight
here and I'm prepared to go two with
this guy so this is one of the
differences you could
know this is the most popular reply to
E5 but now that this is not occupied
with the piece I could consider going
to I think it's also interesting
to uh try out this variation in a way
because uh it
could go into a more positional
territory um
it's not as
common turn into a carocon very
easily exchange
carocon or excuse me an advanced
carocon so it's all righty I
thinker yeah so I was saying on D4 this
takes get that big pawn and my KN still
has access to its favorite
Square what other moves here for White
Knight F3 Knight
D4 a real big thinker
here so okay Knight Knight F3 it is so
something I could consider is maybe F to
this
one yeah I'm going to do that right
now before my knight is on C6 in this
case if Bishop
check that means this Pawn is going to
be around for a bit it's on a light
Square okay this is
another move I've seen and it keeps the
position
open uh and my reply has
been to just sneak by a
step really don't want to recapture with
my
queen so we're going to go
here and I'm going to develop my Bishop
here I think we're close to having some
isolated Queen Pawn position
maybe we'll see what kind of pressure
white places on team black these next
few
moves the check really isn't anything
okay let's see I think I do want to
capture yeah let me
take I think this is the correct
approach what white is doing
here you know given that I've made this
move and underdeveloped I am
slightly behind with
development now I'm a bit concerned
because
H I don't know if I want to allow this
Knight to get to B5
so I'm considering just ruling it
out so if I take Knight B5 is
concerning I mean what do I do I go back
Queen takes Queen I really I'm not
thrilled about being un castled and
having the bishop there coordinate with
the Knight on
B5 so I think I want to negate Knight B5
altoe
yeah I feel like there might be
something here for white given that I'm
still not there recapturing this Pawn
but we'll see if there's some sharp move
here Queen
check and if I block and then
Queen here here making it difficult for
me to recapture I don't know is that a
thing okay I feel like I've been given a
moment to
breathe and now I'm ready to Simply
recapture yeah I should be fine
here and that Bishop is a strong piece
to be
sure let's
get one step away from
castles
and let's just Castle
okay so we have majority's
here
H okay the
pin thinking about this
one on H6 takes Queen
takes maybe there isn't a great knight
Discovery yeah maybe there isn't a great
night Discovery so this one here
here Knight B5 okay I was thinking for a
second on Knight B5 I can take and after
a recapture then take the Knight that's
not
true because on this there's F takes and
my queen is hit no time to recapture the
Knight
so also this this here Knight
B5 I mean I guess I could just move the
bishop Bishop C5
Bishop C5 Knight here Rook
here
H Rook really feels stupid on that
square but the Knight on C C7 in that
position seems like it could easily be
trapped also B5 in that position I have
Bishop Tak pawn pawn takes Queen takes
Rook no queen move to Target The Rook I
think I'm going to go for
that another move I haven't thought of
Thoroughly here is if Knight C6 but I I
mean I could just
capture or even back the bishop off oh
okay well in the end there is no Bishop
takes Knight so I feel like I've been
gifted something a flight Square
okay how
about Queen here this seems like the
most natural Square on some battery
threatening a
sacrifice I'm able to track down this
bishop and prevent any thoughts of a
sacrifice with Knight
G4 so I got that one covered
okay well I think I want to drift
towards the king side somewhat and have
these two interesting squares
available I would really like to track
this guy
down yeah also I could replace
this excellent
Defender if Knight E4 takes here it kind
of helps on my
development so is this is this too slow
Rook B8 and B5 or Rook B8 and just
B3 this Knight jumping here is bit
irritating I don't want to kick the
Knight just inviting the Knight into a
great
Square how do I get my light Square
Bishop out maybe I just play
here
H yeah I'm going to go
here if knight4 I can take Bishop takes
and then Knight
C4 okay so we might be seeing
this what I haven't
considered with this continuation is if
there's a SA sacrifice here on this
move like I should be able to defend
weasel out along the dark squares this
Knight is under control I don't see the
Rooks entering the
scene
okay I mean if I am concerned about that
maybe I could flick in first
F5 maybe that's not a bad
move I don't like weakening this Square
let's see though if the sacrifice isn't
working I'm cool this here here
check um King here Queen here King here
here oh maybe there is a Perpetual
there all right I'm going to do
that I have some Rook lift
Maybe
I'm allowing my queen to help defend
against these sacrifices now this is one
of the benefits of this move but there's
certainly a lot of
drawbacks these holes on the E file also
my time isn't the
greatest another detail I could think
about running I do have a I commented
about this mil okay I got to kind of get
rolling
here play a bit faster
uh I talked about white having a
majority briefly I have the majority on
the king side so that doesn't mean throw
these guys up the board especially with
the queen still on but these two on the
other hand that's a different
story I could look to get here maybe
here shut down this guy well I have to
watch though I am vulnerable along this
diagonal Queen B3 Bishop D5 Queen D5
okay so right here case in point this
move gets hit with this
one so I think I should take
first or maybe keep
the keep the Knight there for a
second um I think maybe to the point is
to take here
first maybe maybe King King in the
corner is correct
yeah I'm going to play King in the
corner okay CU if I did that there's
these checks and then the Knight hopping
into this
Square now the check is not there so I'm
ready to go
E5 pretty much no matter what E5 E4
maybe
F4 forming that duo gives me
nice possibilities here especially with
the queen on E3 Queen and King are on
the same diagonal so this guy ever moves
that one's going to
sting where does this guy
go going there so he's under control by
this
Pawn interesting think I want to get on
this diagonal yeah still keep I'm I'm
still undecided what I want to do with
these this Pond
Duo I wouldn't mind an end game but I
feel like there might be some attack
here for
me this guy is very good also if I push
too soon I'm giving up a huge Square so
I think I just want to sit play it where
this Pawn stays
here maybe I'm leaning more towards
F4 yeah I really don't want this Knight
going here I have to worry about that
um Queen is maybe asking for
some Tempo
here yeah it's complete
development we'll see if this Rook
moves
this
okay
interesting
I'm going to go all the way
back let's go all the way back I'm not
too concerned
about okay actually I should have maybe
inserted that move
first here Bishop C4 Queen takes cuz
then I would have a trick missed an
opportunity to stop this majority from
even rolling I went here to stop an
eventual C5 with
Tempo I think now I want to do something
against this
point
so I'm going to give up this square but
still I'm I'm working on this Pawn
basically that's what I'm saying here uh
but this was I'm not
sure where I'm looking at
it let me put some pressure on this
Knight don't like how I played these
last few
moves I missed that Bishop C4 would have
been a nice
spot to watch for for the Queen Bishop
battery on these should be able to cover
it have Bishop F5 in many
lines so this guy's pinned Queen is
restricted where is there a
trick
um oh wait a second I could play
here
and then I'm ready to do something
here I'm ready to
capture I think I'm winning
now before this guy gets shut
out should be able to get through at
this point so now I think I
take takes Rook I could take here first
I could just
recapture yeah I'm on this guy three
times and it's only defended
once okay I think taking what The Rook
is
best now take with the I'm going to take
with the bishop before it gets shut
out and then
return with my Bishop here keep pressure
on stuff and now I just want to get my
queen over
here so on Rook takes Rook for instance
I'm going to go here here here okay
okay
um what's the story got to move faster
let's go
here Knight here Bishop here Knight here
feels in most most cases it' be a
wonderful piece but I think it's easily
worked around and the attack is going to
be there and my Bishop on
D4 should be
an
animal not sure how you stop the queen
from slithering
in King G2 is another
move even on the clock call it wow I'm
just going to get maybe one more game in
this tournament flies
by especially when you join
late
okay follow through
with Bishop there so that's
fine this this this is happening really
fast
yep most cases this is great but Killer
Bees here threatening a main
two I don't know how that's stopped
really now King here check Rook here to
cover I have this
check this guy is going to be a nonf
factor in trying to defend also this
Knight as well not really a great
defender of the king side and all the
forward
jumps they're
covered I'm not sure what that
does okay might be a loss on
time guess I could pre moove that
one have pressure on this
Rook okay go
here main
one I was going to say even if this I
could play here nope let's
check
okay yeah possible Fork of the queen and
king okay they're out of
time yeah interesting game I think again
I I like how they the approach they took
there in general I think that's the
right
strategy if um I'm playing like that
with Knight F6 E5 and then Knight back
home underdeveloping like that try and
keep the position open let's get a B3
game in opponent berserking I'm sticking
to Rapid play
all right I'm going to stop a quick
E5 take into account the possible Pawn
Duo before thinking about opening this
door now I'm ready for the
door
whoa what's that move about playing like
I did in the last game unprovoked though
all right so this can't be right what is
the idea to get the sea pwn rolling
that's the only thing I can come up
with there's a serious waste of time
there so leaning in my own advice here
we have this under devel underdeveloping
type of
play makes sense to try and rip the
position open
create some tension so
C4 any other
[Music]
move no let's just go with C
form okay and um thinking about just
Bishop takes yeah why
not let the pieces fly out
there all
righty
hm maybe I don't want to
Castle King side just yet so we got two
bees and the queen buing up a lot of
squares on the king side okay gearing up
for this
one what's the
story I don't
know I don't want to block this diagonal
so soon I don't want to just put a pawn
in the center to have a pawn in the
center feel like if I want to do that I
could do it so I'm going to retain some
flexibility with my D
Pawn not mask my Bishop with a
pawn just
yet prefer to do it with the
piece which can always easily move and I
am drawn towards kn2
feel like I could get some attack here
with the miners and the
queen um one thing I have to worry about
maybe a bit is when I play here if
B5 Bishop only has one square but I'm
not seeing how black takes advantage of
that there's not a knight that could
access
B4 straight
away another move that might be
interesting here is G
before yeah I think that's maybe a
move think I'm going to go for
it chop
here we got these guys that are already
out and about invite another piece into
the mix whoa they really are doing
it okay so this is the two-point Pawn I
lost a two-point Pawn
but Black's going going to lose this guy
no kingside castles for black this
Knight is not
stable defend him I kick him oh I miss
that that was even a move okay so Bishop
is defending the Knight Bishop is now
targeting this it's
unprotected um I think this is just a
winning position now so I guess the only
try maybe for black is here and then a
check but I just go here there's no
development for a follow-up attack for
black it should just be
winning may even have takes and then
takes would check something happening
here but I'm thinking mostly about just
taking on G7 right
now and stopping castles and getting on
F7 yeah let's do that I don't care about
this guy going for the going for the
kill here
King
Hunter okay so there's only two pieces
out all right
so Bishop takes Bishop of course as a
move Knight takes E5 as a
move yeah I'm going to go with Knight
takes
E5 I want to kind of H
maybe have access to this F5 Square
takes takes sneak
in so if I play
here let's
see maybe maybe now just taking is
cool you takes and the Knight
here
why not maybe Knight there first I don't
know if
this yeah I don't think that that's
working okay I'm just I'm going to do
yeah this this is this must be correct
actually the more I'm looking at it cuz
cuz two pieces are helped the Knight is
helped the bishop is helped what other
what other move is there for this this
guy
anyhow all
righty thought that was running through
my mind is this Fork but I can move the
Rook at this
point this is covered well enough so I
could take this guy just something more
direct this might be a move here
actually yeah I think it
is Knight takes here I'm on the
queen and I'm on the
bishop
yeah I think this is the are there any
checks no good checks at least so Knight
takes F7
here think should be a
winner Queen being opposite the
king no time to take anything
really so this guy's hit twice defended
zero okay okay so I could take the
queen
yeah
and okay they are getting one of my
Rooks um should be
fine still be
winning the one I care more
about is the one that's on the seventh
rank if this guy moves got to mate in
two
okay now I'm not sure
how mate is
stopped getting made on the seventh
rank check
here and here or here
next and there there we go okay one more
game will be played and will likely not
count 7 minutes to
go
okay let us
see mostly sharp
games yeah I think everyone
turned somewhat
tactical all right some fries here the
flare fries
flare all right uh let's stick with
another
Sicilian another C3 Sicilian
okay let's see if we could get a
different
variation at this point still going to
read revisit this okay so yeah was this
move last time let's go with this
one now takes first and then plant the
pawn here so we're going to see what
White's approach is to this big decision
okay
and I think I'm going to play it in a
similar
way E6
Bishop there I'm not winning
it Knight C3 I don't mind taking
on uh an isolated
Pawn wow very direct play here very
direct is it
correct all right
well I think it's not correct I didn't
see this straight way I should have yeah
I'm I'm just winning this
queen you got the queen check she's a
goner Knight C3 doesn't defend the
queen maybe we get another game we
do yeah you miss that
detail
okay might end up no we're not getting
to the first page
got 20 normally not anywhere close to
the top here joining
late all right team
black D4
E4 D4 okay let's just hit it head
on yes so I think I want
to play an
exchange or not an exchange um an
accepted Queen's gamut
accepted maybe hold off for a move let
me stick with this one first I'm
defending this point with my E Pawn with
an eye on one
day playing C5 possibly
so two steps maybe with this guy all
right Bishop
G5 uh in this case
yeah I'm more inclined
to just break the
pin could end up with the hanging Pawn
structure in this
game yeah all right so this one's
turning out to be a bit more
tame okay just as I say this a move I
did not
expect Bishop takes Knight so I have an
unopposed dark Square
Bishop how can we make it more more
effective I think right now we do that
straight
away right now while this point is
unprotected before it's sheltered
somewhat I get C5 and my queen could
breathe a little bit
more as options further
pressure
ideally dark squares is on my mind put
putting pressure on dark
squares
okay could take
first and then take again
even ideally I'd want to take after take
on C4 after this guy has moved but I
might I might want some clarity in the
center work with a specific structure
Force white to take on an isolated Queen
Pawn
position uh let's
see yeah I think I want to take first
let's see first of all how white
recaptures so I'm taking with my flank
Pawn first before making a commitment
with my Center
pawn and maybe best is to just
Castle am I okay with a ram structure
playing with the bishop
pair yeah keeping this Pawn around it
could be a
Target um it does stop Bishop C4 it
stops Knight E4 bothering my
Bishop let me Castle first uh hang on
hang on hang on
if I Castle in
C5 I'm not there in time actually to
undermine that point Castle C5 B6 B4 A5
A3
[Music]
H position is opening up I do have this
irritating move Knight C5 hitting this
and then ready to break open in the
center so I think I'm I have the correct
type of counterplay if white wow if
white tries to establish a pawn
here but they're they're trying to
attack me that's what is kind of
screaming out to me
here so here's here's the thing I think
taking Bishop
recapture and then Knight
C6 is the way
yeah
let's or I could still start with this
first yeah let me start with this first
let's still not invite
the the
Knight um or the bishop into the mix
just yet so now now I could take here
and oh you know I'm forgetting there is
this this capture idea there is fishing
pole stuff
happening take Bishop takes Pawn King
takes Knight
G5 take there's
this big problem
here so I wonder if I have to play this
one it's not the end of the world that I
allow this file to be opened up and
create these
holes yeah the center is ready to be
blasted open so I I think I want to
think I want to play here stop the
sacrifice attempt the center
is is going to open up in a
blink I don't think white has time for
this attack and certainly I don't think
that this is this is working out cuz
this this point
collapses this bishop is also pulled
away from attacking
my well still attacking my king side
maybe somewhat on this diagonal but
I'd prefer to see the bishop on this
diagonal rather than this one is what
I'm getting at and now I'm ready to just
take
here I think it's best to do it with the
Knight yeah let's go with the
Knight I'm up a
pawn
good think about this move Knight E4 not
really too concerned with having this uh
having this un unopposed
Bishop planted
here super duper
strong so forcing moves this one here
here I don't want to give up my dark
Square Bishop that easily so let's do it
like this in fact now if this guy gets
running I could take and then take here
not too concerned in my dark
squares okay you're going going with
that one actually I am a little bit
concerned here my dark
squares maybe this one and then
here yeah let's run it like
this be b
careful I am ready for this one get rid
of one of the knights
yeah they are putting pressure
on not seeing the mates or anything
though feels kind of close like there
might be
something cuz my King has no squares
after that capture but I think maybe I
could even take on this square if they
play this one a little bit of
calculation also I should have been
looking at a possible Queen check
first that's running through my mind I'm
ready to just take this Knight
here okay they're defending that but now
there's one less attacker near my king
and I believe I have E4
here
yeah simpler ways to play it to this
this here Queen takes Pawn is very good
what's cleanest I think this one
is yeah let's go with that one just
piling up on the pinned
Knight extending the scope of my
bishop and I
think it's perfectly
fine taking here I could still hold
off on this
capture three minutes 40 seconds for
me so what tries are there like two
minor pieces for the queen I'm not
seeing that working
out I'm not seeing a knight get to this
Square for
mate Queen is
around
it's just not there the this Rook is not
playing it's not
enough yeah tough to say what the the
best try even is
here simple just to take with the
Rook don't even
allow possible check it's covered but
all right Queen
there let's crash through I think
and take with the bishop or the Knight
no we'll take with the Knight it's check
easier to
calculate Bishop takes stops Rook
there on the Rook as
well covering
this
Queen takes here Rook here a lot of ways
to do it
now no
mate against the black
king if this Rook leaves Queen G5 is is
looking
good playing that kind of sad to pull
the Rook off of the open file there's
really just nothing here
though also grabbing a pwn
just so I could have Bishop here next is
also pretty
nice yeah I think that might even be
best this is unprotected but no queen
move to even attack it so now we should
just be getting a mate
into the two
Bishops in the
queen okay that's going to do it
in the end one two three the first game
it wasn't really a game one two three
six games
counted uh
six played seven games but really just
six okay I'm going throw a good games
all and that's going to do it for this
one all right Feel Free as usual to
leave any feedback to this video in the
comment section below I hope you enjoyed
it and and maybe took a thing or two
away that's all for now take care
bye